what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel my little
sister amelia
she's super excited to be here and she
was not forced at all
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
okay let's get this show on the road
okay
you clicked on oh by the way she's brand
new to the manosphere she has no idea
what the man of spirit is and who kevin
samuels is
okay but this is a guy that women call
into the show for dating advice
oh boy all right what's the question
well you clicked the request i mean can
you live in peace with a man
can you submit to a man can you play the
background
when you say play the background what do
you mean play the background
play your natural role my natural role
in being a wife
yes the background i don't think a
natural a natural role as a wife is in
the background
show me where in the world the natural
wife is in front
she's not in front but she's beside no
she's not why she's not kevin
are you out of here french toast mine
don't start don't do that now kevin
i'm just giving you my opinion okay well
when a burglar comes
are you standing inside when somebody's
coming to break in the house are you
side by side about beside your husband
or you standing behind him because he's
gonna have to take the bullet
to be honest
i know you're so excited what'd you
think so far
bye
[Music]
damn
well guys bro your dog sounds like she's
looking for you
okay i'll be back